y yo me voy a centrar sobre todo en la
parte que nos concierne acnur que son
todos esos muertos que estamos viendo a
las puertas de nuestros países en los
mares a diario el año pasado fueron tres
mil son cuatro personas que fallecen
cada día en la ruta del mediterráneo
central el oeste y también en el
atlántico y es esa falta de vías legales
seguras para que la gente refugiada para
que la gente migrante bueno pues no
tenga que echar mano de esas mafias que
te sangran y que se aprovechan de esa
desesperación
para poder alcanzar países seguros
porque muchos vienen huyendo de guerras
de violaciones de derechos humanos de
violencia sexual de matrimonios forzosos
y de muchas otras situaciones parecidas
si precisamente en este informe ustedes
hablan de 3.000 migrantes que perdieron
la vida o desaparecieron en el mar
mediterráneo que debería hacer por tanto
la unión europea en materia migratoria
para cambiar esta trágica realidad
bueno hay que hay que ofrecer
alternativas hay que hacer hay que
ofrecer
bueno refuerzo de cooperación
internacional en los países de origen
países de tránsito y de destino también
hay que tener también unas instituciones
de derechos humanos unos procedimientos
de asilo sólidos en estos países para
que la gente que llega transitando y
recorriendo kilómetros no tenga aquí de
un país a otro buscando seguridad es muy
importante también haber abrir esos esos
canales de reasentamiento de
reunificación familiar los visados que
permitirían estas familias que están
separadas no tuvieran que arriesgar la
vida una vez más intentando volverse a
reencontrar y también invertir en
prevención de conflictos y en resolución
de conflictos que es esencial y temen
que esta renuncia al frente de frontex
pueda atraer no puede atraer cambios
reales que sea una renuncia estética que
dicen por parte de los estamentos
judiciales de la unión europea al
respecto de la política migratoria les
dan algún varapalo a las instituciones
europeas y que se dice desde otras
organizaciones
bueno acnur viene abogando desde hace
muchísimo tiempo porque hay adentro del
contexto de la unión europea una
política de asilo armonizada y esto
tiene que ver también con que en las
fronteras se protejan los derechos
humanos donde que no se que no se
produzcan estas devoluciones automáticas
y que bueno si bien los estados tienen
la obligación y de proteger las
fronteras y de controlarlas también
tienen la obligación de proteger a
aquellas personas refugiadas que llegan
a estas nuevas fronteras y no es
incompatible una cosa con la otra así
que lo que pedimos es que se cumpla el
derecho internacional la convención de
ginebra en 1951 y que aquellos
refugiados aquellas personas que si se
las devuelve podrían poner su vida o su
integridad física en peligro que por
favor se las admitan los procedimientos
de asilo